تغطيتنا مستمره وفي تطور لافت اعلن وزير
الدفاع الامريكي لويد اوستن تشكيل قوه
متعدده الجنسيات لحمايه التجاره في البحر
الاحمر في اعقاب هجمات الحوثيين وقال
اوستن في تصريحات له ان الدول المشاركه في
القوه ستنفذ دوريات مشتركه في جنوب البحر
الاحمر وخليج عدن واضاف ان الدول المشاركه
في القوه هذه اضافه الى الولايات المتحده
تشمل بريطانيا والبحرين وكندا وفرنسا
وايطاليا وهولندا والنروج واسبانيا
وسيشل معنا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره فادي
منصور فادي ما الاجواء التي تحيط بما
اعلنه لويد اوستن في واشنطن وما الذي فهم
كذلك من تفاصيل هذا
الطرح
نعم الاعلان الذي جاء في هذا البيان من
وزير الدفاع اوستن خلال زيارته الى الشرق
الاوسط وهو بالمناسبه عاد ادراجه من
اسرائيل وهو حاليا في البحرين جرى التمهيد
له من خلال مشاورات واسعه استمرت لاسابيع
طويله وذلك منذ بدء الحوثيين الهجمات ضد
مصالح اسرائيل في البحر الاحمر ومن ثم ضد
السفن التجاريه المتجهه من والى اسرائيل
دعما لغزه ومن اجل رفاع رفع الحصار عن غزه
ومن اجل وقف العدوان الاسرائيلي كما قال
انصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن وهذه
المشاورات كانت تركز على امكانيه حشد اكبر
عدد ممكن من الدول الراغبه بحمايه امن
الملاحه البحريه وكانت ترتكز في الاساس
على التحالف البحري الدولي ومقره في
البحرين وهو تحالف من 39 دوله معنيه
بحمايه ممرات المياه الحيويه في محيط
منطقه الخليج ومن خلال قوه المهام رقم
153 وهي المتفرعه عن التحالف الدولي وتعنى
تحديدا بامن البحر الاحمر لكن اللافت ان
هذا الاعلان فيه نقطتين اساسيتين على
الاقل ما اعلن حتى هذه اللحظه رسميا على
مستوى الدول العربيه كان هناك حرص واضح من
وزاره الدفاع ومن وزير اوستن وايضا من
الاداره الامريكيه على محاوله حشد دعم
واسع من قبل الدول العربيه وتحديدا من دول
الخليج الاعلان الرسمي اقتصر على البحرين
فقط ثانيا خل البيان من ذكر اسرائيل ربما
بحكم الاشكالات التي قد يثيرها وجود
اسرائيل علنا في هذا التحالف ومساله
الاشكالات السياسيه التي قد تكون متعلقه
بهذا الشان خصوصا مع استمرار الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه والتي حصدت
ارواح نحو 20,000 فلسطيني حتى هذه اللحظه
ودمرت مسيحات ال واسعه من القطاع نفسه
فضلا ع ما يجري في الضفه الغربيه النقطه
الثالثه هناك ارتقاء او ارتفاع في طبيعه
الخطاب الامريكي مسؤول امريكي رفيع يرافق
وزير الدفاع في جولته كان اشار الى ان
مساله استخدام القوه العسكريه الولايات
المتحده لديها خيارات واسعه وقدرات واسعه
للرد على الحوثيين لكنه اعتبر في نهايه
المطاف ان هذه مشكله دوليه وتحتاج الى حل
دولي وبالتالي جاء هذا الاطار النقطه
الثانيه هناك تحميل مباشر لايران عن ما
يقوم به الحوثيون من استهداف الشحن البحري
المتعلق بمصالح اسرائيل هذا المسؤول قال
ان ايران هي التي تقف وراء هذه الهجمات
الجميع يعلم وفق هذا المسؤول ان ايران
سلحت ومولت وتدرب الحوثيين لكنه قال شيء
لافت للغايه اذا قررت ايران ان تتوق قف
هذه الهجمات من قبل الحوثيين في اليمن فان
هذه الهجمات سوف تتوقف وبالتالي الولايات
المتحده تتعامل مع هذا الملف كما تعاملها
مع ملف حزب الله في لبنان في سله واحده
وبان في نهايه المطاف المرجعيه عن كل هذه
الامور هي ايران وهناك هدف واضح هي ايران
لكن ايضا كان لافتا من هذه التصريحات ان
الولايات المتحده تريد من الدول الغير
راغبه بالمشاركه على
في هذا التحالف خوفا من اي تداعيات عسكريه
في حال وقعت مواجهه مع الحوثيين ان تعلي
الصوت بوجه ايران وان تندد بايران بسبب
دعمها الحوثيين وهذا امر اعرب اكثر من
مسؤول في البنتاغون عن خيبه الامل من عدم
وقوف دول كانت تراهن الولايات المتحده
عليها وان تتصدى لايران بشكل مباشر وكلنا
نتذكر مساله التطبيع التي حصلت لا سما ما
بين ايران والسعوديه والتي كانت برعايه
صينيه وبالتالي هناك الكثير من الاشكالات
التي تحف هذا التحالف في نهايه المطاف هو
مبادره تحاول الولايات المتحده ان توسع
المشاركه فيها وان جاء الاعلان الحالي
مقتصرا على الدول المعروفه وهي حديثه
الولايات المتحده في اطار حلف شمال
الاطلسي النيتو ودوله صغيره بقدراتها
العسكريه بطبيعه الحال وان كانت مهمه
استراتيجيا للولايات المتحده وهي البحرين
لكن السؤال الابرز هل سيستطيع هذا الحضور
المتعدد الاطراف فعلا اولا ان يعيد الثقه
لشركات الشحن خصوصا فيما يتعلق بنقل
البضائع لاسرائيل او النفط او غيره من
المواد لاسما ان البنتاجون يقر بان
الحوثيين يمتلكون اسلحه متطوره للغايه من
بينها الصواريخ البالستيه المضاده للسفن
وايضا المسيرات الجويه واحداها ضربت اليوم
سفينه في جنوب البحر
الاحمر شكرا جزيلا لك فادي منصور مراسل
الجزيره من
واشنطن